(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] We've got some
fans. We got got a few fans.
- Thank you!
(audience wooing)
- I mean, I swear to God
don't think Harry Styles
gets that kind of entrance here.
That was amazing!
Did you-
- Harry Style doesn't hang
out in the parking lot.
(Kelly and Gabriel laughs)
- I love a good tailgate. So I'm there.
Do you know Laura, have
y'all ever met before?
- No, I thought I thought it was so cool
the fact that we both said
it's nice to meet sincere,
like wow.
- Yeah.
- It was like, so cool.
- Yeah. You're both very kind.
- Thank you.
- Yes. So wait, this is huge.
So, you're the first
comedian to ever do standup
at Dodger Stadium.
First of all,
I said to her up for email,
I was like, doing Dodger
Stadium, that's amazing.
You know people fit in there?
(audience cheering)
That's incredible.
Are you freaking out?
- It's very surreal
because I've been to the
ballpark a million times,
been going there since I was a kid.
And so the fact that
this show's gonna happen
it's the biggest thing I've ever done.
And it's at home.
- [Laura] Isn't that amazing?
(audience cheering)
- I know, that's so cool!
Do you get excited about home
crowds or do you get nervous?
- I used to get really
nervous about home shows
'cause then you get the phone calls,
'Hey man. What's up?'
People I haven't heard
from all year, you know?
(speaking foreign language)
I'm like, 'great. I
gotta hook up tickets'.
(Kelly laughs)
Right?
And then just people coming up
that I haven't seen in a long time.
So it's a little extra pressure.
- Do you say ticketmaster.com? (laughs)
- [Gabriel] Nice.
- [Kelly] Do you send them there?
- Well, first of all,
with Mexican families it's
hard because they guilt you.
- Yeah.
- Somebody know what I'm talking-
- [Woman In Audience] Yeah!
- I think you don't have to be Mexican.
All families will.
There's a level of guilt happening.
Yes.
- But they bring in
religion and your childhood.
(audience laughs)
- Oh. So does Southern Baptists.
- [Gabriel] Oh, okay. (laughs)
- Like all religious people
can bring that in there.
Dodger Stadium holds tens
of thousands of people.
And here you are,
in the early days performing
for around 10 people.
- [Gabriel] Oh wow.
- [Kelly] You've come a long way.
Since, when I said, that's amazing.
- [Gabriel] Oh man.
- [Kelly] Do you remember
these kind of shows?
- [Gabriel] I try not to.
(Kelly and audience laughs)
- [Kelly] But these are
the ones that mold you
into who you become.
- Yeah.
And see, I guess ignorance is bliss.
Because back then you don't
know what a bad show is.
You don't know-
- Yeah no.
- No bad moments or situations.
Cause you haven't been around long enough
you're just happy to be working.
And so when someone says,
'you wanna perform and hold
a microphone next to a pool?'
- [Kelly] Sure.
- Yeah. Why not?
Yeah. Let let's do.
If I would've dropped that,
(Gabriel and Kelly laughs)
- It's over.
- Let's get electricity as
close to the water as possible.
(audience laughing)
I've done shows in backyards,
off of the back of pickup trucks,
inside of empty swimming pools,
because the guy said it
was good for acoustics.
(audience laughs)
- Well-
- Yeah right.
- I don't know if he's wrong there.
- Meanwhile it looks
like I'm going to fight
Van Damme down there.
You know what I mean?
It's all empty.
There's still water.
- Fight Van Damme. (laughs)
I will say though, one of my first gigs,
I sing at a wrestling match,
the National Anthem,
but I didn't know what
wrestling was really,
or what that was gonna look like.
And so I borrowed a friend's dress
and it was a really
nice black, long dress.
Like I was going to
like prom or something.
- Yeah.
- And I was whoa fish out of water.
I was ready to feel like Whitney Houston,
and all these other people
were like in tank tops.
Have you ever had that happen with work,
like in the audition-
- Oh yeah, all the time.
When you're overdressed or underdressed.
And everyone else got
the memo and you didn't.
You might as well be standing
there in a chicken suit.
- Wow.
(Gabriel laughing)
I've actually been in
a chicken suit party.
(Kelly and Gabriel laughs)
So, it's a true story.
So here you are,
- $20 is $20.
- You know what?
(all laughs)
You know what? I was
trying to win a contest.
So here you are with your first check
for doing a comedy show.
Look at your little face!
(audience cheering)
- [Gabriel] Oh.
- [Kelly] Your little
face with your a braces.
I love you!
- Oh my God. Yeah.
- It's $435, 79 cents.
So what show was that for?
- It was for my first
television show appearance
on Comedy Central's show
called 'Make Me Laugh'.
And I did the show and
when I got the check,
I'm like, 'it took me two
minutes to make this'.
And then my head, I did the ghetto math
where I'm like,
- [Kelly] Ghetto math.
- Ghetto math where I'm like,
'if I did this for eight hours,
how much, you just start
having those fantasies-
- Yes.
- Of-
(audience cheering)
Yes.
- Do you remember the
first thing you bought
with your first professional money?
Do you remember what-
- That right there, yes.
And I still have it.
A leather jacket from
Wilson's House of Suede.
- I bought a coat. I bought a coat.
I remember that. Yeah.
- It had the liner with the zipper, right?
And then it had the thing-
- [Kelly] Oh. Where you
could take the, yes!
Oh, it was bad. I still got it.
- [Kelly] Fancy.
- Still fits too. What?
- Fancy.
(audience cheering)
- I was remembering something
I bought and I was like,
'well that's yesteryear.
Can't fit into that.'
So do you remember your
first acting paid gig though?
- I was an understudy for a play called
'Six Degrees Of Separation'.
Out of school, which was a Broadway show.
That was amazing.
I was the happiest understudy ever.
Like most understudies were sort of like,
'yeah, I'll never going on',
but I loved it.
I would sit in the catwalk,
I would sit way up high and watch a show.
I loved it to pieces.
Yep.
- I love that.
I love those moments too,
where I still get excited.
I hope I never get jaded like that.
You know, you're run into
people that get jaded.
- Oh it's only.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] Yeah. Yeah.
- And I don't know where
the accent came from
but that's how I sound when I look at-
- I love that she becomes an old smoker
and then you, (laughs)
- I become British.
You become an old British man. Really.
- I say. They're trying
to pay me in pesos.
(Kelly and audience laughs)
- British pesos.